every day i turn off onto an old country
road it's about a mile from the
presidents but you can see them
and then you get up to them and you
stand next to one and you go man
these things are huge
how many people
on earth can say they've got a
collection of presidents in their
backyard that you can see from space
i know there's jfk
i have 43 presidents
and ronald
these guys weigh approximately 14 to 21
000 pounds these things are huge aren't
they they've been here for about three
years and through time they're starting
to enjoy being out here they've got
their wildlife i got a business
the weeds are growing up it's amazing
they amaze me
these statues were once a part of a
outdoor park
when the original park had closed its
doors i was asked to destroy the
presidents and clean the place up
[Music]
it hit me i said i'm not destroying them
i'm going to figure out something
the feeling i get from them it's
it's overwhelming i mean these guys they
still have strength today that they had
when they were alive and form in our
country
they mean a lot to me
i want to bring them back to
a museum where they can be enjoyed by
everybody
[Music]
here we are
in the whole valley rainforest
this
is a cathedral
my cathedral
in this forest is the quietest place in
the entire united states and it's only
one square inch in size
my mission is to keep it that way
i'm gordon hempton i'm a soundtracker i
travel the globe in search of vanishing
sounds including the most endangered of
all which is simply
silence
noise pollution
is nearly inescapable
the hoe valley is the quietest least
noise polluted place in the entire lower
48.
i don't know if i can save silence but i
know that i can try
[Music]
so it was 12 years ago 2005 earth day
that i hiked up the ho river valley
it took three miles just to escape the
noise of the parking lot
[Music]
that's when i was looking in every
direction for which way i should go
[Music]
i saw the elk trail love to follow their
advice because they love quiet just like
i do
and they led me right to the spot
it's just
through that tree
and off into the woods
i defend this one square inch of silence
by doing both quiet and noise monitoring
when a noise intrusion occurs i locate
the noise maker send them a letter and
ask for compliance
this matter is urgent
within 10 years it's likely that there
will be no quiet places left unless we
take action
[Music]
when i first started i did not think
silence would go extinct in my lifetime
and if that happens the quiet will
disappear and the wildlife will be
devastated
the one square inch of silence
foundation is pressing our politicians
to pass a single piece of legislation
that will designate olympic national
park as the world's first quiet park off
limits to aircraft
all things are possible
the earth is here
and it's beautiful
and for me
it all starts here in the hoe valley
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to be able to be doing science while
you're out there on a surfboard surfing
down the face of a wave it's just such a
fleeting moment it's incredible to
actually be able to do it
smartfin is a surfboard fan
you clip it on the bottom of your board
you go out for your surf session
it has technology that measures ocean ph
salinity ocean temperature and very
detailed wave characteristics so there
will be an enormous amount of data
the reason these parameters are
important is because they are shifting
directly as a result of climate change
we had detailed information about the
deep ocean but very limited accurate
information about the near shore
satellites can't be really accurate with
data in that narrow zone and the other
way is ocean buoys and they're just not
deployed at the coast
bingo smartfin can fill that gap
collecting oceanic data is a very
time-consuming expensive process
this is like you just need to know how
to surf
the data moves from your fin
to your phone via bluetooth and then
from your phone it goes up to our
servers where everything's processed
i had to develop sensors that don't
affect the surfboard nobody's going to
surf a fin that is not a standard foil
aside from that led right there that's
blinking that tells you that there's
like some sort of technology in there
you wouldn't know the difference
[Music]
so we've got a test tank set up now
and we're just trying to
look at the precision and accuracy of
the instrument itself
things are looking pretty promising
as a scientist it's pretty exciting to
be able to get data over these different
time and space scales
i mean the fact that you can go out and
surf and contribute to understanding
what's actually happening out there is
incredible
i'm not a surfer i know nothing about
surfing i know i look like a surfer but
um
i'm not
surfers are very influential and care
deeply about the environment and want to
be talking about it so smartphone is
just a tool to do that in a more
concrete way
[Music]
remember finding nemo the movie that
introduced us to clownfish love your dad
dory the absentminded sidekick now has
her own movie but marine
conservationists they're not excited
they're actually kind of worried
[Music]
this right here is a blue tang the
real-life dory they only live on coral
reefs in the south pacific but before we
get to her story let's talk about nemo
the clownfish when finding nemo came out
well okay i'll let karen tell you i'm
karen burke da silva i'm a marine
biologist and a conservation biologist
here at flinders university of south
australia
so what happened with finding nemo after
the release of finding nemo we found
that there was quite a big increase in
the number of people that wanted a clown
fish as a pet with the increase in
demand it did have an increase in
captive breeding but it also meant that
more fish were being taken from the wild
and in fact
some places there's been so much over
collecting that clownfish have gone
locally extinct
oh so captive breeding seems like the
way to go
back to dory the blue tang if her movie
has the same effect as nemo's moviegoers
are sure to want to buy a blue tang of
their own but there's a problem and you
are
my name is matt dimaggio i'm a assistant
professor at the university of florida
tropical aquaculture laboratory ah okay
matt so what's the problem clown fish
are relatively easy to raise in
captivity but up until now no one has
raised blue tangs in captivity blue tang
larvae are inherently difficult to raise
they have a very small mouth when they
hatch out so the food particles that we
have to offer them
are much smaller and much more difficult
to raise
the best success we've had to date is
using a zooplankton called a copepod the
couple pods that we grow here only eat
live microalgae
so you now have to grow live microalgae
to feed to the cobblepots
basically raising blue tank so far is
really really hard which means a hundred
percent of blue tang are currently being
taken from the wild for the aquarium
trade most collectors in australia will
use uh very careful collecting measures
in other parts of the world southeast
asia they are using cyanide steel to
collect
aquarium fish
that's not good
but there's hope matt and his team are
working hard to breed blue tanks
successfully there's only one other tank
species the yellow tank that's ever been
raised in captivity before
we're hoping that the blue tang will be
the second all right so until they do
when little johnny says he wants a dory
perhaps the better choice for now at
least is to stick to the blue beta
or a goldfish
[Music]